MARKETING TACTICS OF THE COMPANY
THAT MADE THE GUN USED IN THE
UVALDE SHOOTING.
OUR TOM FOREMAN IS "OUTFRONT"
WHICH.
>> LOOK AT THE CONTRAST.
THE RAW PANIC CAUSED BY A YOUNG
MAN WITH AN ASSAULT RIFLE AND
THE SLICK PROMOTIONAL VIDEO FROM
THE COMPANY THAT MADE IT.
>> WE LOVE TO BUILD GREAT GUN.
>> THAT'S MARTY DANIEL, FOUNDER
OF DANNY DEFENSE, WHICH
AUTHORITIES SAY MADE ONE OF THE
WEAPONS USED BY THE UVALDE
SHOOTER AROUND HIS 18th BIRTHDAY
AND WHICH POSTED THIS
PROVOCATIVE IMAGE OF A TODDLER A
WEEK BEFORE THE SLAUGHTER.
>> IT'S MORALLY UNCONSCIONABLE,
I'M SHOCKED BUT NOT SURPRISED
SOMEBODY IS DOING THIS, OF
COURSE THEY ARE BECAUSE THEY CAN
AND WILL MAKE MONEY DOING IT BUT
THEY NEED TO STOP AND NEED TO
EITHER, WE EITHER SHAME THEM
INTO STOPPING OR LEGISLATE OR
REGULATE THEM INTO STOPPING.
>> Reporter: THE COMPANY TOOK
THAT IMAGE DOWN, YET
GEORGIA-BASED DANIEL DEFENSE IS
A SMALL FIREARMS COMPANY WITH A
BIG KNACK FOR HEADLINES.
>> MY FAMILY'S SAFETY IS MY
HIGHEST PRIORITY.
>> Reporter: FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN
THE NFL REFUSED THIS DANNAL Y'S
AD FOR THE SUPER BOWL BECAUSE IT
PROMOTED GUNS, MARTY TURNED THE
REJECTION INTO AVALANCHE OF
ATTENTION.
>> THE MAJORITY OF THE SUPERBOWL
FANS HAVE THE SAME VALUES THAT
WE HAVE AT DANIEL DEFENSE, AND
THAT IS WE BELIEVE IN PROTECTING
OUR FAMILIES.
>> SHAME ON YOU!
>> Reporter: GUN CONTROL
ACTIVISTS SAY THE COMPANY IS
CLEARLY GOING AFTER YOUNG
CUSTOMERS WITH NODS TO POP
CULTURE ICONS AND VIDEO GAMES,
WHILE MARTY KEEPS RAILING ABOUT
GUN CONTROL FOR THE OLDER SECT.
>> THE ANTISECOND AMENDMENT
CROWD LOOKS FOR ANY EXCUSE TO
BAN GUNS ANY WAY THEY CAN.
>> Reporter: AMID THE ANGER
AFTER UVALDE, PULLING OUT OF
THIS YEAR'S NRA CONVENTION.
THE COMPANY SAYS WE ARE DEEPLY
SADDENED BY THE TRAGIC EVENTS.
WE WILL COOPERATE WITH ALL
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITIES IN THEIR
INVESTIGATIONS.
THAT PLEDGE MAY BE TESTED.
CONGRESS IS ASKING DANIEL FOR
DETAILS ABOUT HOW HE OPERATES,
NOTING YOUR COMPANY CONTINUES TO
MANUFACTURE LARGE QUANTITIES OF
ASSAULT WEAPONS AND AGGRESSIVELY
MARKET THEM TO THE PUBLIC.
THE DEADLY IMPACT OF YOUR
PRODUCTS IS BY DESIGN.
AMID ITS MESSAGING OF GUNS,
SHOOTING SPORTS, AND GROWTH.
>> IT'S THE QUALITY WE PUT INTO
EVERY PRODUCT.
>> WE ASKED DANIEL DEFENSE FOR
ANY FURTHER COMMENT, STILL
WAITING ON ANYTHING MORE FROM
THEM, WORTH NOTING, THOUGH, THAT
MESSAGE FROM CONGRESS SAID THEY
FOUND WEAPONS FROM DANIEL
DEFENSE IN THE ROOM WITH THE
SHOOTER IN VEGAS YEARS AGO WHEN
THE PEOPLE WERE KILLED AT THAT
CONCERT THOUGH.
THAT'S THE KIND OF SPOTLIGHT
THAT EVEN COMPANIES LIKE THIS
THAT KRAFB ATTENTION MAY NOT
LIKE MOVING FORWARD.
>> TOM FOREMAN, THANK YOU FOR
THAT IMPORTANT REPORTING TONIGHT
PPT LET ME BRING YOU A TEXAS GUN
CONTROL ADVOCATE WHO AT GREG AB
ABBOTT'S REQUEST WAS ON TWO TASK
FORCES IN 2018 AND 2019, THANK
YOU FOR COMING ON TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME.
>> BOTH OF THOSE EFFORTS ENDED
UP RESULTING IN NOTHING, NO
MEANINGFUL GUN REFORMS PASSED IN
TEXAS AFTER THE MASS SHOOTINGS
IN 2018 AND 2019 AND YOU SAY
DESPITE THIS HORRIFIC MASSACRE
IN UVALDE AT THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL, YOU DON'T THINK ANYTHING
WILL CHANGE.
WHY?
>> IT'S -- IT'S UNLIKELY AND
BELIEVE ME, WORKING IN THIS
FIELD FOR SO LONG, IT HURTS MY
HEART TO SAY IT, BUT THROUGH MY
EXPERIENCE, IN 2018 AND 2019,
YOU KNOW, BEFORE YOU EVER STEP
INTO THE RING WITH SOMEONE YOU
NEED TO BE VERY CLEAR-EYED ABOUT
YOUR OPPONENT, AND I LEARNED
THAT OUR STATE LEADERS, AT
LEAST, REALIZE THE DANGER,
THAT'S OUT THERE, THE THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY, BUT THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO BUCK THEIR BASE WHICH
IS BECOMING MORE AND MORE
RADICALIZED WITH EACH DAY.
IN THESE MEETINGS, THE GOVERNOR
STARTED THEM BY BEING OPEN TO A
RED FLAG LAW, SOME LAWS
REGARDING THE REPORTING OF
STOLEN FIREARMS, STRONGER
STORAGE LAWS, WHICH WAS A GOOD
START, AND IT, AND HE ENDED UP
ABANDONING ALL OF HIS PROPOSALS
WHEN THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION
STARTED SO THAT JUST GIVES YOU
AN IDEA.
>> OUR VIEWERS LOOKING AT VIDEO
OF YOU SITTING NEXT TO GOVERNOR
ABBOTT, THIS IS MAY OF 2013, AND
YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT MOMENT
SAYING, 2018, YOU WERE
SURPRISED, BUT WELCOMED THAT HE
SEEMED VERY RECEPTIVE,
ESPECIALLY THE RED FLAG LAWS YOU
BROUGHT THEM UP, SAY THIS PASSED
IN INDIANA, SAY, WELL I'M
PARAPHRASING, IF PASSED IN A RED
STATE SHOULD BE LIKELIHOOD IT
COULD DO WELL HERE AND THEN THAT
COMPLETELY, COMPLETELY CHANGED.
BUT HE DID SAY THIS WEEK,
GOVERNOR ABBOTT, THE STATUS QUO
IS UNACCEPTABLE.
BUT YOU HAVE NO FAITH IN THAT?
>> WELL, YOU HAVE TO PARSE THE
WORDS AND READ BETWEEN THE
LINES.
HE SAYS THE STATUS QUO IS
UNACCEPTABLE, BUT WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
I'VE ALSO HEARD HIM SAY ALL THE
LAWS PASSED IN 2019 WILL BE
REVISITED, WELL THAT WASN'T VERY
MUCH.
I THINK -- I WAS IMPRESSED IN MY
INITIAL MEETINGS WITH HIM, HIS
BREADTH OF KNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ISSUE IS
VERY DEEP.
HE KNEW WHAT A RED FLAG WAS,
KNEW WHAT THE CURRENT
REGULATIONS WERE AND THAT WAS A
GOOD START.
SO THEN, WHEN HE ABANDONED THE
PROPOSAL AND RAN AWAY FROM IT
THE FIRST TIME, I CAN SAY HEY,
YOU KNOW, I KNOW THERE'S
POLITICAL PRESSURE BUT THERE WAS
NO EXCUSE FOR THE SECOND TIME
NOT DOING ANYTHING AND HE AND
OTHER STATE LEADERS INCLUDING
OUR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR MADE
CLEAR SIGNALS THAT THEY KNEW THE
DANGERS THAT WERE OUT THERE AND
THAT WERE POSED BY THIS.
OUR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR SAID HE
WOULD TAKE AN ARROW TO THE HEART
TO OPPOSE THE NRA TO PASS
EXPANDED BACKGROUND CHECKS WHILE
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT?
NOTHING.
AND THE PEOPLE OF TEXAS AND THE
PEOPLE OF THIS NATION NEED TO
REALIZE THAT THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE.
THEY RAN FROM THEIR PROPOSALS
BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID OF A
BASE THAT WILL NOT BEND.
SO THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO BE VERY
REALISTIC ABOUT THE PROSPECT OF
TALKS HERE.
AS LONG AS THEY STAY IN POWER,
AS LONG AS CONGRESS STAYS THE
WAY IT IS, THE STATE LEGISLATURE
STAYS THE WAY IT IS, IT IS GOING
TO GET WORSE.
PREPARE YOURSELVES FOR THAT.
SO WE JUST -- THAT DOESN'T MEAN
WE GIVE UP.
WE JUST HAVE TOO RECOMMIT AS
INDIVIDUALS AND FIND NEW WAYS TO
CONTINUE THE FIGHT.
>> AND YOU NEED THOSE VOICES
WITH THE SEAT AT THE TABLE AS
YOU